ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht ich bin
ein bisschen muss ich sagen überwältigt
wenn man sich mal zurück sind und
überlegt was wir da gerade gesehen haben
es ist fast so als wäre hollywood
einfach die realität geworden wir leben
in der schlimmsten pandemie die wir alle
hier erlebt haben und auch mal neben 400
von der begeisterung vom kollegen strunz
bin ich der meinung dass das eine viel
inszenierung war also lady gaga und
jennifer lopez bei all ihren verdiensten
haben im moment nichts auf diesen bühnen
zu suchen und der joe biden hat das
genau richtig erkannt joe biden hat nach
diesem gebäude und letzten endes war ja
trump ein roller der in allen reden laut
war man hat sich immer sorgen um die
frisur gemacht hätte dem wind stand aber
was er gesagt hat ging eigentlich vorbei
an den herzen der menschen und das hat
joe biden richtig gemacht mein eindruck
vergessene lady gaga vergessen wir die
die jennifer lopez der der der pummelige
garth brooks der waren noch finde ich
bei den amerikanern weil das mit amazing
grace und mit seinen mit seinem
schlapphut jahre einmarschiert ist und
der die hände schüttelt der der ist und
auch amun bedarf müssten aber joe biden
hat einige wichtige dinge geschafft
erstens die rede war dynamisch das war
kein alter mann der da vor sich hin
gefaselt hat sondern wer hat im grunde
tatsächlich den richtigen ton getroffen
und er hat auch die größe gefunden
diesen armen pence der da saß in seiner
rede mit hineinzunehmen und hat dadurch
den tramp noch mal in die ecke gestellt
der ist nicht mal geschafft hat in
seiner verabschiedung joe biden beim
namen zu nennen und er hat ein paar
dinge gesagt die in der jetzigen zeit
ganz wichtig waren
er hat nicht von america first
gesprochen nicht von amerika amerika
geräte gehen sondern relativ demütig vor
der welt gesagt wie a good people
schätzt uns bitte nicht da ein wo uns
die vorherige regierung hingebracht hat
via good people
und er hat auch gesagt my soul ist also
er hat von einer seele gesprochen hat ja
den 1
trump hatte überhaupt keine seele dieser
mann hat emotionen gezeigt er hat gefühl
gezeigt er hat diese rede wahrscheinlich
vom prompte abgelesen und die war sehr
wohl kalkuliert aber er hat sie in einer
form von menschlichkeit schon
glaubwürdigkeit rübergebracht die mich
mehr beeindruckt hat als das goldene
kabel von lady gaga das ist das was wir
im moment brauchen diese ehrlichkeit der
hat die pandemie beim namen genannt und
er hat immer wieder betont diese
einschätzung war ja schon bereits
richtig dass wir an einem punkt stehen
wo wir einen neubeginn wagen müssen wo
wir uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen
dass was schief gelaufen ist ich habe
ein bisschen mit diesem armen pelz
gefühlt er da saß der der weihe einer
der täter der hat ja mitgewirkt den
laden so hat auch gesagt während er hat
ja den laden in die grütze gefahren mit
seinem kumpel und jetzt sitzt er da aber
allein die tatsache dass es sich
hinsetzt spricht für und das ist aber
jetzt die ganz entscheidende frage wie
umgehen mit den menschen die die letzten
vier jahre regiert haben denn für die
wurden von 75 millionen gewählt
abgewählt aber auch von 75 millionen
wert und wir sind zwei zitate von joe
biden in der region geblieben das eine
ist dem motto on our watch
die demokratie ist nicht gestorben unter
unserer verantwortung und das zweite
zitat america has been tested america
has been tested ist der satz für poltawa
der satz für nine eleven nicht
eigentlich normalerweise nichts ersatz
für vier jahre präsidentschaft wird joe
biden mit dieser einordnung und diese
einordnung ja auch der wähler die
dot.com gewählt haben wird er es
schaffen mit dieser einordnung quasi
eines kriegs von innen der die letzten
vier jahre geführt worden ist wieder in
göttern das land so zu vereinen wie er
sich das auch mal vor ich kann ist
diesem land zu wünschen jetzt wo sich
sagen man hatte ja fast den eindruck
dass die beiden wie wir
weihnachtsbotschaft zu allen menschen
gesprochen hat die guten willens sind er
hat eine gewissen teil der amerikaner
wahrscheinlich damit nicht erreicht wie
beleidigten die beleidigten leberwürste
aber er hat ja sich auch an die an der
hat ja gesagt wir wollen die
mittelklasse wieder aufbauen damit
gesteht er zu
dass die mittelklasse in amerika
weggebrochen ist also eher will
reparieren er ist als der große heiler
angetreten und den braucht es auch im
moment und das hat er ganz klar
definiert und das rechne ich ihm hoch an
er hat gesagt er hat den mann
geschrieben der abends schlaflos in
seinem bett liegt an die decke start und
sich fragt wie soll ich die miete
bezahlen das ist natürlich immer bei den
amerikanern etwas verlogen begonnen walk
through this together
natürlich hat er eine bessere
medizinische betreuung als jeder andere
amerikaner wir reden über jemanden der
47 jahre berufspolitikers deshalb
trotzdem average djia your average joe
der mann der die menschen versteht kann
man das sein
nach 47 jahren mein schiff zeit ist
eigentlich auf man will es glauben er
hat das gesagt was ich von ihm hören
wollte inwieweit das der wahrheit
entspricht kann man nicht sagen und das
ist das problem der politik im
allgemeinen er hat ein verständnis
gezeigt von dem ich nur hoffen kann dass
er auch so auch wirklich hat und dass er
die möglichkeiten hat den die amerikaner
werden es ihm nicht leicht machen er hat
jetzt nicht gesagt werden alle eure
waffen weg aber das war eine zutiefst
friedliche rede
das war nicht eine rede die in
irgendeiner form den nationalstolz
weiter gebauchpinselt hat wie bei trump
das immer der fall war
er hat eine gewisse demut gezeigt und da
bin ich sehr skeptisch dass die
amerikaner das in der form so aufnehmen
wie wir es gerne hören
auch obama wer uns ja im grunde aus der
seele gesprochen hat der auch yes wie
can einen neuen anfang signalisiert hat
hat ihm ja so nicht hinbekommen weil ihm
diese großartige nation nicht so gefolgt
so heftige von absolut nur zur hälfte
gefolgt ist und das war auch eben mein
eindruck es war eine rede an die hälfte
der nation und bei der hälfte ist sie
vermutlich fabelhaft angekommen ich muss
persönlich sagen ich weiß nicht wie sie
es sehen wenn ich mir die bilder vom
kapitol vor wenigen tagen noch einmal
vor augen führe und davon ausgehe dass
diese menschen vielleicht repräsentativ
sind für das was in der anderen hälfte
amerikas los gibt der mann mit dem
büffel kopf erreicht man dies wird sich
glaube meine seele ist
wisst ihr ich glaube sie sind nicht
repräsentativ das ist eine gruppe von
wild wie eine wild gewordene aufgehetzte
horde die man in jedem land der welt mit
dem richtigen maß befehl in bewegung
setzen kann
es gibt einige und ich kenne einige
davon wenn man es nicht zutraut die
trump fans sind sie können es nicht
richtig definieren einer den ich sehr
respektiere einer meiner freunde hat
gesagt er ist jetzt so many things also
er hat so oft recht was his way to act
ist herbel also man war der meinung der
der ist ein teil von jener kraft die
stets das böse will und doch das gute
schafft im umgekehrten sinne er hat also
durch seine aktionen amerika in verruf
gebracht weil beim rest der welt und die
amerikaner die an geglaubt haben die
klugen waren enttäuscht und die trottel
habe gesagt er muss nur noch war richtig
der muss von uns nur noch unterstützt
werden und das geht eben nur noch durch
randale
jetzt sehen wir die beiden gerade wir ja
hin dass schüttelt tatsächlich hände
schüttelt dort auf den stufen des
kapitols so wie man das tatsächlich seit
langer zeit nicht mehr gesehen hat geht
rein um und schüttelt hände thomas
ziehen und malen sich zu vertrauen in
den armen auch gut zum fällen der behält
steht da bisher isoliert ja ja ja ja ja
dem wird mit dem das wird mir auch ein
phänomen in washington
der ist ab sofort radioactive und das
weiß er auch mit dem wird in den
nächsten jahren also da wird deutlich
weniger freunde haben als in den letzten
vier jahren hatte noch einmal eine ganz
persönliche frage ich habe das
eigentlich gesagt es ist fast wie eine
szene aus dem hollywoodfilm eine
pandemie dass die der rasen vom kapitol
ist leer
joe biden spricht quasi im übertragenen
sinne zumindest von einem krieg denn der
eigene präsident gegen das land gegen
das land geführt hat was sind ihre ganz
persönlichen gedanken als jemand der in
amerika so tief verankert ist in diesem
moment was wünschen sie sich für amerika
und auch wenn sie jetzt einmal diesen
tag nutzen um zurückzublicken auf die
letzten vier jahre was geht ihnen da
durch den kopf ich bin in der generation
groß geworden
die aufgeschaut hat zu amerika amerika
war unser wunsch bild das war der duft
der großen weiten welt amerika new york
los angeles hollywood und das ist
natürlich gewonnen dieser traum ist in
irgendeiner form zerflossen aber ich
glaube tatsächlich dass die amerikaner
uns immer noch etwas vormachen können in
ihrer fähigkeit zur regeneration in ihre
fähigkeit sich selbst im grunde wieder
an den eigenen haaren aus dem sumpf zu
ziehen indem sie geraten sind die
mehrzahl der amerikaner und da gebe ich
dir dein recht we are good people
das sind sie dann bekommen wir
vielleicht noch einmal doch ganz kurz zu
dem thema schau bis zu wir haben lady
gaga gesehen wir haben jennifer lopez
gewinnen alle eben vor dieser lehre der
pandemie ist dass sich vielleicht auch
ein zeichen von regeneration dass diese
leute wieder auftreten ist das nicht
auch eine ein zeichen von einer gewissen
hoffnung etwas wonach so viele menschen
sich sehen nach dem konzert nach musik
nach diesem zusammensein wieder
miteinander
aber ich finde dass diese beiden welten
wenig miteinander zu tun haben also
super bowl jahr
das ist nichts anderes als sport das ist
circus maximus das ist im grunde
präsentation das ist show und hier war
immer auf eine interessante weise wie
die politische wirklichkeit die pandemie
und alles was uns umtreibt im grunde in
das waren so das waren so als wären da
auf der auf dem auf der auf der torte im
ein paar noch ein paar erdbeeren plus
damit es nicht ganz so schaurig wirkt
aber es war eine inszenierung die die
eben inszenierung war das hatte keine
logik keine menschen keinen beifall
das ist da hast du gemerkt irgendwas ist
da nicht richtig da ist da ist irgendwas
falsch in diesem film
was glauben sie was jetzt zur beiden der
in diesen momenten das capitol verlässt
und sich auf den weg begibt diese
berühmteste adresse der welt 610 handel
pennsylvania ins weiße haus was wird
seine priorität jetzt sein um das was er
ja angekündigt hat das land zu heilen
dann auch wirklich umzusetzen
also ich weiß ja dass die amerikanischen
präsidenten mehr macht haben als bei uns
politiker ich weiß auch nicht ob die
dynamik ob dieser schub den wir jetzt
eigentlich haben sollte reicht und ob
dies aber mal die betroffenheit der
republikaner groß genug ist um zu sagen
lasst uns jetzt dem erfolg beweisen dass
wir den schuss gehört haben das wird man
sehen das kann man nur hoffen und ich
selber bin ja im moment in einer
situation wo ich gerne nach kalifornien
reisen würde
aber man kann einfach nicht also dieses
festgenagelt sein
diese ausgangssperre die ja irgendwo
auch eine psychische die macht ja was
mit einem menschen wie bedrückt mich und
diese fehlenden sozialen möglichkeiten
ich bin ja ein hochgradig kommunikativer
mensch und muss mich jetzt beschränken
das ist schwierig und da muss man sehen
wie die politik in der lage ist das
jetzt auszuhebeln und etwas zu bewirken
obwohl nichts weitergeht
das wird mit der impfung auch zu tun
haben also die die amerikaner sind ja da
weiter als wir offensichtlich da muss
man alle räder welt sind inzwischen
eigentlich weiter das ist ein anderes
thema wollen wir versuchen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren